oh no what are they doing oh no oh my
god oh no all right this is a perfect
example of sometimes the evidence just
speaks for itself this is this is awful
and hilarious
[Music]
hey legal eagles D James Stone here
teaching you how to think like a lawyer
today we're gonna review better call
Saul episode 1 this is really exciting
for me because I loved Breaking Bad and
the character of Saul Goodman was
particularly good because he gave such
good legal advice of course it was legal
advice in the context of a drug-dealing
psychopath but still good legal advice
nonetheless be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to make sure that you never
miss out on a future lawyer reacts and
of course be sure to leave your comments
in the form of an objection I will
either overrule or sustain your
objections based on their legal merit
and of course stay until the end when I
give better call Saul episode 1 a grade
for legal realism so without further ado
let's dig right in - better call Saul
episode 1
it's on judge would use this voice god
that is exactly what courtroom bathrooms
look like they're just out of the last
century they've got those weird push-up
soap dispensers just horribly dirty okay
this is uh this seems pretty accurate so
far
and that's so funny because lawyers
really do practice their opening and
closing statements in the bathroom
before they go into court that is
probably where you'll find most trial
attorneys when court is about to start
all right he gave himself a pep talk oh
to be 19 again okay you can never just
storm in to the middle of the well the
area between counsel table and the judge
it does seem like there is a prior
relationship here between the judge and
Saul Goodman given that the judge sent
the bailiff into the bathroom to get him
I'm guessing the judge has interacted
with Saul many times before so he's
giving him some leeway but you can't
just burst in there like that but it
seems like he may have had prior
permission to do that so we'll keep
watching okay but if you're being honest
I mean really honest
you'll recall that you also had an
underdeveloped nineteen year old brain
me personally I if I were held
accountable for some of the stupid
decisions I made when I was 19 oh wow
and I bet if we were in church right now
you get a big Amen this is really good
what Saul Goodman is doing is he's
making himself seem personable your
credibility is everything when you're in
front of the jury
so you want to make it seem like you are
a relatable person you're just another
member of the jury so he's doing a great
job of seeming self-deprecating and
forming an emotional connection with
this jury in this what looks like a
closing argument so so far very good
which brings us to these three now these
three knuckleheads and I'm sorry boys
but that's what you are
they did a dumb thing that's also really
good when you have bad facts you need to
get ahead of them to front run them and
to show that you're aware of those bad
facts but to downplay them and to show
that they aren't dispositive to your
case so I like what he's done he's
actually making his own clients seem
personable they're young they're
knuckleheads as he put it he is making
them seem relatable but also showing
that they have made
mistake and trying to get ahead of
whatever bad facts are against his case
it's so far pretty good fact one nobody
got hurt
not a soul very important to keep that
in mind
fact 2 now the prosecution keeps
bandying this term criminal trespass mr.
spenalzo the property owner admitted to
us that he keeps most portions of his
business open to the public both day and
night so trespassing it's bit of a reach
do you think they've oh man I really
like this as well keep in mind that a
trial can go on for days and sometimes
weeks so there are hundreds if not
thousands of facts
dozens of people testifying a trial is a
very complex thing
so what Saul Goodman has done here is
reminded the jury of two and only two
facts because a trial is really really
complex and he just wants them to focus
on two things that are particularly good
for his case so he points out that no
one got hurt which may be important from
a legal perspective in that one of the
elements of whatever crime they're being
charged with may be triggered by bodily
harm
but more importantly it shows on an
emotional level that there's no need for
the jury to punish these boys because no
one was hurt so it dovetails on the
emotional and then the second thing that
he focuses on is the legal requirement
for criminal trespass not being made if
the property owner gives consent to
someone entering their property then
these boys can't be guilty of the crime
of criminal trespass so he's focusing on
the one hand on the emotional trigger
that no one was hurt and also on the
legal trigger that the element of
criminal trespass isn't met so out of
all of the things that the jury learned
in trial he focuses on these two salient
points which are both good for his case
and I think that that is a very good way
of going about your closing argument
here's what I know
these three young men near honors
students all clear honors feliz erodes
one Saturday night and they just a
little bananas I don't know call me
crazy but I don't think they deserve to
have their Bright Futures ruined by a
momentary minut never to be repeated
lapse of judgment
another good emotion Lemoine you're
bigger than that that's really good
there are two rhetorical devices that
Saul Goodman is using here to great
effect the first is that he is referring
to the dramaturgical so he is putting
the jury up on a stage showing them that
people are watching and number two he is
ascribing the values that he wants to
the jury he's saying that they are
bigger than that hoping that they will
rise to the attribute that he is already
ascribed to them so those are two killer
persuasive techniques that Saul Goodman
has used here oh god what have they done
oh no he's just gonna show a video so
because this is closing argument all the
evidence has already come in so the
prosecutor doesn't have to lay any
foundation all of that has already been
established during the course of the
trial and the judge has already approved
or denied all of the exhibits including
god only knows what's going to be on
this videotape oh no oh my god oh no all
right this is a perfect example of
sometimes the evidence just speaks for
itself in Latin that's the phrase race
if loquitur the thing speaks for itself
and frankly sometimes it doesn't require
any legal argument you just show the
thing itself and that's bad enough
sometimes you don't need to gild the
lily or pound the rubble it's just bad
enough as it is and if I was the
prosecutor in this particular case I
probably would have done the same thing
just show the tape let it speaks for
itself and let the jury decide this
doesn't need any argument at all this is
this is awful
aunt hilarious how kind of math is that
700 per defense no no defendant dint
three defendants 2,100 which by the way
bargain what I did for them they going
to jail Langer sausage what does that
matter so I guess in this case Saul is a
public defender as you may know there
are two types of government attorneys in
this context there are the prosecutors
who
are employed by the state to actually
prosecute those alleged of crimes and
then there are also public defenders who
provide a defense to those who can't
afford one it goes back to the 1960s to
a Supreme Court case called Gideon
versus Wainwright which held that under
the sixth amendments protection to a
trial defendants were required to have
an attorney because if they didn't have
an attorney the right to an impartial
trial would never be upheld because it
would be inherently unfair
so under Supreme Court precedent if you
cannot afford an attorney you are
provided a public defender now that only
applies in the criminal context it does
not apply in the civil context if you
are sued civilly you're basically on
your own and that's where attorneys like
me a civil attorney come in and we save
your bacon you can tell me what this
twenty six thousand supposed to be for
that's money for Chuck isn't that what
you wanted
a measly 26 grand Jesus you're like
Peter Minuit with the Indians throw in
some beads and shells while you're at it
it's just a start there'll be more
unless you're gonna just tear them all
up and why was it made out to me why not
Chuck so he personally told you that
it's his wish to withdraw from the firm
see that would surprise me
it's been nearly a year since he set
foot in here okay so one of the reasons
that Jimmy may not want to cash this
check or have his client cash this check
is that there is a doctrine in most
jurisdictions that says that even if you
don't have a written contract an express
contract that is spelled out and has all
the terms you can sometimes enter into a
contract by your conduct so I think he's
worried about the idea that if he cashes
this check he may tacitly agree to the
terms of this settlement with this other
law firm and therefore give them the
deal that they want which is not a deal
that Jimmy or his client wants so I
think he is worried about forming a
settlement contract by his own conduct
but I guess we'll see six hundred thirty
bucks is that for one fall to two falls
in one day
even at your age that's gotta hurt
true that right well I got a job for you
that's two grand sounding too grand for
one hit one hit plus you get to learn
from the best okay I probably don't need
to tell you how unethical it is for an
attorney to go out and pay people to
fake an injury and basically defraud
some poor victim but let's talk about
some of the nuances here if they were to
go forward with this plan they would be
engaging in fraud and would be liable
for civil and potentially criminal fraud
now on top of that they would not be
able to get compensation for whatever
injuries that they have of course fraud
creates an affirmative defense to the
kind of allegations that they would want
to create but more fundamentally they
lack what's called standing in the u.s.
system in order to go forward with a
civil suit you have to have standing you
have to show that you have suffered an
injury and when you intentionally engage
in this kind of conduct you negate the
kind of staining that would give rise to
an injury so not only will they not be
able to get compensation because they
have defrauded someone but they also
lack the underlying elements of the the
civil suit that lacks standing and they
lack in actionable injury so if they
ever get caught this is not a good thing
for them all right
okay that was the first episode of
better call Saul and it did not
disappoint I really look forward to
reviewing future episodes of this series
it's great but now it's time to give
better call Saul a grade for legal
realism so let's think about this well
we have realistic depictions of the
monotony of courtroom life we have some
really good arguments being made trying
to appeal to the jury's emotional state
we have big firm attorneys being jerks
we have the unglamorous life of an
attorney who is just trying to make ends
meet and we have literal ambulance
chasers who are throwing themselves in
front of cars all in all we have a
realistic depiction of a lot of the
parts that go into a lawyer's life that
rarely get any screen time with only
minimal
dramatic license so I'm giving better
call Saul episode 1 and a - for legal
realism well done so hit that belt to be
notified of my next reaction and check
out this playlist I put together that
includes all of my prior reactions
including my reaction to suits The Good
Wife and many others so click on that
playlist and I'll see you in court